AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND OUT OF A
COURTESY TO ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE GONNA LET MISTER
BLOOM GO AHEAD AND PRESENT.
ON AB.
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE IT WILL ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION SOON AS
WE GET HARM -- MEMBERS -- AND
MEMBERS ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
ARE AN INNOVATIVE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTION FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS IN OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THOUSANDS OF BEEN
DELTA PERMITTED ACROSS THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY BARRY AT AND
THAT'S AS A RESULT OF MY
LEGISLATION AND AND A NUMBER OF
OTHERS BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE STILL BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION IN A B. EIGHT EIGHT
ONE SIX TO REDUCE SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS BY UPDATING.
AND CLARIFYING PROVISIONS OF THE
EIGHTY YOU STATUTE THERE'S NO
COST TO THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN LEVEL FEES TO COVER
THEIR COSTS.
AND I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT
EIGHTIES ARE COST EFFECTIVE TO
BUILD.
AND HELP INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS WITHOUT
DEPLETING LIMITED STATE FUNDS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU YOU
HAVE IN.
ANY -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THOSE MARIN TAKE FROM CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
NAME'S LOUIS MONTANA FROM
CALIFORNIA BE -- CALIFORNIA BE
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF UB'S
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DUBBED DOZENS OF YOURS TO WORK
TO MAKE THEIR NEIGHBORS.
I NEIGHBORHOODS -- TO A GROWING
COMPANY MORE NEIGHBORS.
I STRONGLY IN SUPPORT TODAY OF
AB -- EIGHT EIGHT ONE IT REMOVES
ONE OF THE LAST REMAINING POLICY
BARRIERS -- TO WIDESPREAD.
EIGHTY YOU'D OPTION IN
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY.
A REQUIREMENT IN MANY CITIES IS
A LARGE BARRIER FOR HOMEOWNERS
WISHING TO BUILD EIGHTIES IN
THEIR BACKYARD.
I NOTICE THE PHYSICAL COMMITTEES
WILL TRY TO KEEP IT TO THAT --
FEES LOCAL FEES ON THE PLANNING
PROCESS CAN ALWAYS COVER THE
COST OR ANY COSTS AT THIS BIT
BILL OR ANY OTHER EIGHTY YOU
POLICY WOULD IMPOSE SO THE
MANDATES LIKELY NOT REIMBURSABLE.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO TELL ME
ASSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DO NOT HAVE A FILE THIS TIME.
I THINK YOU.
OF WHICH I CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
I THINK YOU WE WILL TAKE THAT UP
OF COURSE WHEN WE GET ENOUGH
FOLKS HERE ALSO YOU HAVE A B.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ALSO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I DO INDEED THANK YOU AGAIN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ENACTED REGULATIONS
TO RESTRICT THE USE OF SECOND
GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT WROTE
DOWN TO SIDES.
AFTER ALARMING DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF WILDLIFE FOUND
THAT NON TARGETED WILDLIFE WERE
SUCCUMBING TO SECONDARY
INFECTIONS LIKE MANGE.
DUE TO THE WAY THE RODENTICIDE
AFFECTED THEIR SYSTEMS AT THESE
REGULATIONS HAVE NOT RESULTED IN
A DECREASE IN SECONDARY WILDLIFE
POISONINGS INSTEAD THEY'VE
STAYED CONSTANT OR INCREASED IN
SOME SPECIES.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF SECOND
GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO
PROHIBITS THE USE OF FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE ON STATE OWNED
PROPERTY THERE IS LITTLE OR NO
COST TO THE STATE AND THE DPR AS
THE STATE.
HAS ALREADY IMPLEMENTED MOST OF
IT'S SET UP A PROPERTIES SO AND
IS HELPS INTO MUD IN IMPLEMENTED
A NO ANTICOAGULANT POLICY THAT
AND THOSE PROPERTIES.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THANK YOU -- AND WE'LL TAKE THAT
UP WHEN WE ENOUGH FOLKS HERE
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR STONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES THE LAW TO
ALLOW PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST TO
SHOW UP MAKE THE COPIES
THEMSELVES WE'VE RECENTLY TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO PROTECT.
SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS OR VALUABLE
DOCUMENTS AS WELL AS LIMITED
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
USE EQUIPMENT ON SITE.
BUT THIS NOTION THAT.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS HAVE TO DO ALL
THE COPYING AND IN CHARGE THE
PUBLIC IS A BIT OUTDATED WHEN WE
ALL CARRY SCANNERS IN OUR
POCKETS OR PURSES.
THAT.
ADEQUATELY DO THE JOB I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU -- JUST SO SO WE NOW
SAID THAT AB ONE EIGHT ONE NINE
AND AB ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IT WILL ENJOYED YOU
PASS RECOMMENDATIONS AND AS WE
HAVE ENOUGH FOLKS HERE --
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE LIKE THAT
UP.
WHEN WE GET PEOPLE HERE
[inaudible]
MISTER DALI.
MR ONLY A INDUSTRY AND I'M --
EXTENDING A VERY SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE TO YOU TO NOT.
WRASSE YOU ON I A VERY BRIEF
PRESENTATION OF YEAR SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE UP I'LL START WITH A
BE.
A TWO FORTY SEVEN AB -- TWO
FORTY SEVEN IS A BILL THAT
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA PICK UP THE
REMAINING COST.
A LOT LAST YEAR WE HAD SEVERAL
FIRES MY DISTRICT WE HAD THE THE
CAR FIRE IN THE TIME OF ON FIRE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- YES
PICKS UP A BIG PORTION OF IT
THERE'S A SMALL PORTION THAT IS
LEFT OVER.
AND I'M REQUESTING THAT THE
STATE PICK UP THAT COST TO HELP
US KEEP OUR LOCAL SERVICES --
INTACT IN OUR COMMUNITIES THERE --
LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE PROTECTION
AS WELL SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE AND
I BUT WHEN THE BILL COMES UP.
ALSO LIKE WE'RE GONNA TAKE THESE
EACH ONE JUST BECAUSE I HAVE.
TO ARE YOU DON'T IS ALL ON AB
TWO FORTY SEVEN YES YES ARE
THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR ONE
MOMENT I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND STOP MOTION FORM WHICH
IS GOOD FOR ALL OF US MADAM
SECRETARY [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAPTER DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG.
GABRIEL.
SO SO YOU'RE FOR GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
NORTH QUIRK HERE READ THIS.
ALL RIGHT -- BACK TO SUPPORTERS.
ON AB TWO FORTY SEVEN GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CAROLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SISKIYOU IN CHESTER COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT CRITICAL LEGISLATION
THANK YOU -- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NON DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CHECK VAST RIGHT OUT.
AND THAT'LL GIVE ME DISPENSED
FILE LATER -- TO DATE AND I
THINK YOU ALSO WE'RE GOING TO A
SHORT PRESENTATION ON EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY THREE YES MANAGER
AB. EIGHTY THREE SEVEN REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO ASSESS.
HOW MUCH HABITAT AND WILDLIFE
WE'VE LOST DUE TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE AS YOU KNOW WITHIN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WE BURNED OVER
ONE POINT SIX MILLION ACRES WE
SPENT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PROTECTING WILDLIFE AND
HABITAT?
NOT ONLY STATEWIDE BUT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS WELL SO THIS
BILL ACTUALLY WOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO QUANTIFY HOW MUCH HABITAT
WILDLIFE WE'RE LOSING STATEWIDE --
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS BILL IS
THAT -- WE'VE DONE A LOT --
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE IN
IMPROVING -- FOREST PRACTICES
ACT -- ON PRIVATE LANDS BUT WE
DON'T REGULATE FEDERAL LANDS AND
AS YOU KNOW -- DURING THE
CAMPFIRE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
THAT TO KNOW WHAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO TAKE CARE THEIR FORCE
WE'VE DONE A LOT IN OUR AREA.
BUT THE BIG SHARE OF WILDLIFE
AND HABITAT THAT'S BEEN AFFECTED
IS BEEN ON ACTUAL FEDERAL LAND
SO WE CAN QUANTIFY -- WHAT HOW
MUCH WE'VE LOST AND WE CAN
ACTUALLY GO TO CONGRESS AND THE
SENATE AND -- GOT AND THE
PRESIDENT ASKED HIM TO HELP --
DO THE SAME THAT WE DOWN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN PROTECTING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE A FEW
REDUCTION SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL AS
WELL.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
I WILL TAKE THOSE UP -- MM
SUSPENSE FILE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I DO WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY BILLS -- THAT COULD BE
PRESENTED ON TODAY AND ADD
DESPITE MY AND BIPARTISAN SHOW
OF SUPPORT RIGHT THERE SO I I
DON'T ANTICIPATE WILL HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE.
PRESENT IN ON SUSPENSE BILLS --
BUT OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE RIGHT.
TO AT WE HAVE MULTIPLE BILLS
WE'VE HEARD NOW THAT WE HAVE --
FOLKS HERE AB I NEED A MOTION
YES ON AB SO MOVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK IN A SECOND BY -- MISTER
BIGELOW IN THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER BLOOM.
SO MOVED A MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRK.
A SECOND.
BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
YEAH MR CHAO SORRY I JUST HEARD
IT OVER THERE -- IN THAT IS ON
CALL.
AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BY
MISTER STONE.
I WORK IN A SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE AND THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT WE GOT
THIS GOING NOW.
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING.
I DON'T SEE MISTER [inaudible]
MS GARCIA.
GOOD MORNING I AM.
TOO AB -- ELEVEN FORTY FIVE I'M
AT.
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE YEAH I'M
WAVING PRESENTATION ANALYSIS AND
SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I AB ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE SIMPLIFIES A LOT FROM
MANDATED REPORTERS.
AT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NO
IT'S NEGLIGIBLE CLASSES
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
UPDATE TRAINING MATERIALS FROM
MANDATED REPORTERS.
KERN REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS OF CHILD
ABUSE ARE CONFUSING INCONSISTENT
AND DISCRIMINATORY.
THE BILL SIMPLY MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO REPORTING
VOLUNTARY AXE.
A SEXUAL CONDUCT ALL TYPES OF
SEXUAL CONDUCT GET THE SAME
TREATMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS EIGHT MEN --
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ABLE.
IRATE -- THAT BILL IS GOING TO
GO ON CALL BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND -- FOR NOW
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU.
YOU'RE DONE I'M SORRY.
I I GUESS BECAUSE YOU'RE SITTING
THERE MISTER MEDINA.
MR MEDINA YOU HAVE AB FORTY FIVE
IT ENJOYS I HAVE MULTIPLE BILLS
LET'S GO THROUGH I'M EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION CAN YOU START
WITH THAT [inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT
A. B. FOUR EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE SIX TO EXPAND
CURRENT LAW. TO INFORM THE
PUBLIC WILL DETAIL.
INFORMATION OF BEFORE LOCAL
DISTRICTS APPROVED TAXPAYER
FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS KOREA IN A SECOND
BUT AFTER QUIRK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CNN SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IRON ALL
TOMORROW BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION.
WITHIN MOST OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL ARE FINE WE JUST HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION THE WAGE
RATES THE BENEFIT PACKAGES THE
CONTRACT RATES AND WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE -- IN REGARDS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR REPLACEMENT OF
WORKERS WITH AUTOMATION TO ADD
THE TERM -- IF KNOWN IN REGARDS
TO WIN -- RETAILERS WOULD KNOW
ABOUT THE TIMELINE FOR
AUTOMATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
KAREN CIRCUITS HERE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE OPPOSED AS AS AND LESS
AMENDED.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
FILE [inaudible]
JUDGE CLOSE.
BERKELEY AFTER I WROTE.
WE'RE AND PUT THAT ON CALL.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE WE GET
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HERE WE CAN
TAKE IT OFF.
AT MISTER MEDINA YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL BILLS LET'S SEE
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
YES -- AB SIX NINETY FIVE
EXTENDS THE CURRENT.
SECONDLY COLLEGE DESIGNED BILLS
STATURE THE TWENTY THIRD.
YEAH THE MOTION BY MISCREANT A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK YOU'VE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES YOUR AYE VOTE.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR PEROT NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
MR DEEDS.
HE'S NOT HERE SO OF COURSE IS
NOT VOTING.
MR MEDINA AB TEN NINETY ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB TONIGHT IT WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO WAIVE.
ANY MANDATORY CAMPUS BASED FEES
FOR SURVIVING SPOUSES AND OUR
CHILDREN OF DECEASED LAW
ENFORCEMENT MOVES DOWN FOR
FIREFIGHTERS WE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND BY THE
ENTIRE PANEL -- MISTER BIGELOW.
YEAH WOULD YOU SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTEEN OH FOUR ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FIFTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS -- TO
DO THE SAME AS UC AND CSU
STUDENTS AND LOBBY.
AT AT MOTION BY MS CARILLO
SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN -- DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
BUT SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE FILE.
I THAT ONE'S GONNA GO ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA THANK
YOU [inaudible]
REALLY PRESENTATIONS.
MR LOWER YOUR NEXT UP.
MR LET YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WERE IN START WITH AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MOTION BY
MEMBER.
MIGHT AFFECT THEIR FEARS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE WE
HAVE SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF A COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. TO A SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE THANK YOU THAT GETS ON A
ROLL CALL MR LOW YOU HAVE AB.
SEVEN ZERO SIX WE MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS RESPECTIVE ACTS THE
TRANSFER LEASE RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROBABLY IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IN A FINANCE NO FILE THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB NINE THIRTY TO ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WHERE MOTION BY MISTER BUTLER A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FIREFIGHTERS WORKERS
COMPENSATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FRANK OF?
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DOUG SERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS POLICE
RESPONSE OF THE BILL AND THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR MOVING
BRING IT FORWARD AND ENCOURAGE
I'VE A THANK SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON OUR A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE WELL DONE
[inaudible]
MYSTERY MESS.
I'M SORRY IN THAT IT IN IN ALL
FAIRNESS APPARENTLY MISS REYES.
SO SWEET OF YOU SERVICE.
THIS IS AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION -- SORRY.
I'M DOING ROBERTS BILLS --
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY NINE I CAN'T
READ IT -- IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SECOND THING IF YOU THINK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY MR BIGELOW IN A SECOND BUT
AFTER QUIRK SPEAKERS AND UPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA PRACTICAL SPONSORED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MARKETS GO THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK ALSO PRACTICE SPONSORED
I REQUEST RIVAL THANK YOU.
ANY SPEAKERS OPPOSITION SEE NINE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THIS RACE.
MYSTERIES YOU HAVE AB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE BILL SHOULD BY MISS KOREA IN
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
I MISS APPROPRIATIONS.
WE MISS YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT MY
GOODNESS SOMEONE TO COME BACK --
THIS ALLOWS THE INSURERS AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND HIS OFFICE
RECEIVE NOTICE OF PROP SIXTY
FIVE APPEALS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MARIO DIBERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOU
EVER THE SERRA I WAS A SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL TO SIMPLE BILL
ASKING FOR NOTICE ON OF APPEALS
IMPROPER. SIXTY FIVE CASES WE
SPECTRUM.
BUT THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. TO SEE.
NINE FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOON AS WE GET IT'S GOING TO GO
ON CALL.
AND THEN A AS SOON AS WE GET.
ONE MORE FOR A PERSON HERE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONE MORE
DEMOCRAT HERE
.
MS FREEMAN WE LIKE TO GO YES.
WONDERFUL.
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT YOU ON THE
COMMITTEE WHY YOU ARE HERE BUT
THAT DOESN'T WORK AB FORTINO
SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL WITH THE MOTION BY
MS CARILLO AND A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS A VERY GOOD BILL
ABOUT TRYING TO STOP RECKLESS
DRIVING AND STREET RACING ON OUR
STREETS -- I REQUEST AND I BOTH
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU.
AT YOU WAVE THAT YES SMART ONE
MISS WICKS.
HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS I WANT TO
WAY PRESENTATION ON AB.
SIXTEEN OH THREE YES WE WILL
HEAR FROM ME ON AB TWO ART NINE
TWENTY THREE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT HAPPY TO SPONSOR COST
SAVINGS FROM MARK FOR MISTER
PAUL BOSTROM.
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAUL
BOSTROM AND THE ENERGY DIVISION
MANAGER FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT
OR BARK.
AB NINE TWENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
PARTS PURCHASE ELECTRICITY
DIRECTLY FROM THE CHI SO.
AS WELL AS OTHER GENERATORS AND%
POWER MARKETERS.
THE STORY IS CONSISTENT.
WITH PARTS DESIGNATION AS A LOAD
SERVING ENTITY UNDER THE CHI SO
TERRACE WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALTHOUGH
SERVING ENTITIES EXCEPT FOR
BOARD ARE CURRENTLY PERMITTED TO
BUY ENERGY DIRECTLY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR.
WHOLESALE MARKET.
BART IS COMMITTED TO MEETING ITS
ELECTRIC POWER NEED USING CLEAN
ENERGY SOURCES OF POWER.
OR HAS ADOPTED PROCUREMENT
POLICIES THAT INCLUDE THE GOAL
OF MAXIMIZING PROCUREMENT.
FROM LOW IN ZERO CARBON.
SOURCES OF POWER INCLUDING
RENEWABLE RESOURCES.
AB NINE TWENTY THREE WILL SAVE
BARTON ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR WITHOUT INCREASING
COSTS IN ANY WAY TO THE STATE OR
OTHER MARKET PARTICIPANTS.
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO WELL.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
WELL I'M SO SORRY MR BIGELOW HAS
A QUESTION.
THIS WHICH IS MAYBE -- FOR THE
FOLKS REPRESENTING PARK BUT IN
IN HERE THIS BILL ALLOWS YOU TO
ACTUALLY PURCHASE AT THAT
DISCOUNTED RATE FROM THE EYES OF
OR ANY OTHER FACILITY.
BART LOOKS TO GET PERMISSIONS
AND IT IS BEING GRANTED THROUGH
THIS BILL -- TO ACTUALLY BECOME
A RESELLER -- IS THAT REALLY THE
INTENT OF BAR TO ULTIMATELY
BECOME A MASS RESELLER FOR THE
ENTIRE BAY AREA.
NO SIR WE ARE HAVE NO INTENTION
OF RESELLING ELECTRICITY IN ANY
WAY BART IS NOT CHARACTERIZES
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION POWER
MARKETER OR SIMPLY BUYING POWER
TO SERVE OUR OWN NEEDS RIGHT I I
WANTED AN ON THE RECORD JUST.
FOR CLARITY BUT IT DOES GIVE YOU
THE ABILITY TO RESELL IIS WHAT
WHAT IS ALSO OCCUR HERE SO I
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TAKE IT OUT ON A
RECORD THANK YOU.
SO MISS WEEKS BEFORE YOU GO ON
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
SOME BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL IN
CAN BE DISPENSED OF WE HAVE A
MOTION ON ALL OF THESE CRACKED.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER BLOOM GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE BY
MR MEDINA GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB.
FIFTEEN OH FOUR BY MISTER MEDINA
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AND BUT MR BIGELOW MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING NO.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE BY MISS
RIOS GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
WITH THAT MISS WICKS AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION GREAT.
THANKS.
AB.
FOURTEEN I'M BY DOCTOR EGGMAN IN
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
ESCRIBIR AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILED.
THANK IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH THAT MISTER DEEP NOT VOTING
TO MISTER FONG NOT BUDDY THANK
YOU MISS WICKS THANKS.
MR SALAS COME ON DOWN.
AB SIX THIRTY FOUR ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB. FOR
SIMPLY AT ROUNDABOUT SENSE OF
CATEGORY OF STATE HIGHWAY
FACILITIES LIKE ME NAME BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MEMORIAL
DESIGNATION.
THE MOTION AND SECOND THE
MEASURE BY MISCREANT A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
IN A FINANCE.
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE APPROVED
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT
CALTRANS ESTIMATES COSTS FROM
THIS BILL WILL BE MINOR
OBSERVABLE [inaudible]
AS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
WE ASK PRIVATE THAT BILL PASSES
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING --
EXCEPT MISTER OBERNOLTE WHOSE
BODY.
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MYSTERY THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GO.
MYSTERY MESS HAS AB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO THIS ENJOY THE DO PASS AS
AMENDED [inaudible]
RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL.
A MOTION BY MISCREANT A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK MORNING MADAM
CHAIR -- COLLEAGUES IN SO YES I
DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS --
APPRECIATE STAFF'S SUGGESTIONS
AND SO THIS BILL AB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO IS RELATED TO THE
DISTRIBUTION OF CAL EPA GRANTS.
IN PARTICULAR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE -- SMALL GRANTS PROGRAM
IS SPECIFICALLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT WOULD GIVE THE CAL EPA
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS TO GRANT AWARD IS
RATHER THAN THE USUAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR APPROVED
PROJECTS IS SHOWN IT DOESN'T
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO SUPPORT
AND HELP.
THOSE SMALL ORGANIZATIONS -- YOU
KNOW USES FIND THE RIGHT WAY.
AND SO WITH US WE DO HAVE --
EIGHTY SPOTSWOOD EL ALL OF HER.
YES SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS JAMIE
GO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RELIEF AN ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
TO URBAN FORESTRY AND URBAN
GREENING WE WANT TO KEEP IT
REALLY BRIEF FOR THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND WE DON'T BE
REDUNDANT ON THE NEED AND
PURPOSE OF THE BILL BUT GIVEN
THAT THE BILL.
ONLY CHANGES THE STRUCTURE IN
WHICH CAL EPA AND WHEN THEY CAN
ADMINISTER GRANT FUNDING ON THE
FRONT END VERSUS THE BACK AND IT
SHOULDN'T AND KERR ANY STATE
COSTS AND WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT
ON THE GENERAL FUND.
AND HE ALSO HAS ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS FOR WHICH THEY CAN
DETERMINE IF AND WHEN THESE
GRANTS.
ARE GRANTEES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING AND WE ALSO ACCEPTED
THAT MEN MEN'S AS A MYSTERY THAT.
THAT DESCRIBED SO WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
I THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
THANK YOU AT MYSTERY WRESTLING.
I LIKE TO ASK THE NOVEL THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THING.
NO WE'RE PATTERSON.
AB THREE TWENTY ONE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I'M JUST WONDERFUL BUILT NUMBERS.
AFTER QUIRK IN A SINGLE I MISS
CARILLO. THREE TWENTY ONE SEEKS
TO BRING HER TO THE LAW
REGARDING TAXATION FOR
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS AND TRAILERS
USED INTERSTATE.
COMMERCE APPRECIATE THE UP.
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO PASS THIS
PARITY WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA MUCH
MORE COMPETITIVE FOR SELLING OUT
ONLY TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
TRAILERS AS WELL I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
FIGURES IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES
THEY'LL BE NO REVENUE LOSS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
CITY TFA EXPECTS SOME --
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS HOWEVER
COST ESTIMATE IS STILL PENDING.
THANK YOU WHICH I CLOSE THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
.
THIS GONZALEZ YOU HAVE A EIGHTY
NINE YOU HAVE A PASS
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL SPONSORED MY BY MY
LOCAL DA.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE OF THIS BILL GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS OF STANDING
MISTER ALL NOKIA'S AND NOW MR
DEEP IS NOT THANK YOU.
JUST IMAGINE WOULD YOU LIKE
[inaudible]
TO PRESENT [inaudible]
SHE WE HAVE BURNER HARD
[inaudible]
THE OUT OF RESPECT I'M SORRY MR
MAIENSCHEIN I DIDN'T SEE ONE OF
THE OTHER MEMBERS IN CENTER
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
CAN CAN I ASK YOU JUST WAIT JUST
FOR MOMENT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME ON A THIS.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
AB SIX EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
WERE REQUIRE EQUAL PRIZE PAY FOR
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN ATHLETES.
MOVE ON STATE LANDS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER WERE.
AND THIS BILL WOULD HAVE A MINOR --
AN OBSERVABLE FISCAL IMPACT TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S THAT
REVIEW LAND USE PERMITS FOR
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES PURPOSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NUMBER.
YES THERE IS.
JERRY TEN BUT YOU DON'T WANT
LINES INTO.
FOUR A REAL BRIEFLY SHERRY
PEMBERTON ON BEHALF O THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
WITNESSES IT.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF I'M ONLY.
SIXTY SEVEN ON THE COAST OKAY
WITNESSES A OPPOSED -- MY NAME
IS SABRINA BRANDON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING TEN
ORGANIZATIONS BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB FOR SIX
SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED.
THE COMMITTEE FOR EQUITY AND
WOMEN SURFING THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY HARPER DISTRICT.
ATHLETE ALLY THE HOME STRETCH
FOUNDATION SURF CLUB OF THE
CLAREMONT COLLEGES BECAUSE I
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS.
ON THE WATERFRONT.
I A P. FILMS GOOD FILM WORKS AND
DOCTOR MERRY LORRAINE S. A. B.
FOUR SIX SEVEN DOES NOT PROTECT
ATHLETES FROM GENDER BASED
DISCRIMINATION -- PLEASE SEE OUR
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT AND PLEASE
AMEND AB FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO OPPOSE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE FILE.
ON THIS COURT.
YES I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
SURFING -- IN PARTICULAR --
PERHAPS THE OPPOSITION CAN'T
TELL ME WHAT THEIR CONCERN IS
BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU -- SO WE HAVE TWO
CONCERNS ONE CONCERN IS THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT -- PROTECT.
ATHLETES FROM GENDER BASED
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
ATHLETIC COMPETITIONS ON STATE
LANDS TO CONTINUE.
THAT DO NOT INCLUDE.
CATEGORIES FOR MEN IN CATEGORIES
FOR WOMEN MEANING THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A SURF COMPETITION OR SAY --
A BICYCLE RACE OR SOME OTHER
KIND OF ATHLETIC COMPETITION
THAT ONLY HAS -- ATHLETES OF ONE
GENDER COMPETING THEREFORE
BECAUSE THE BILL HASN'T CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE THIS BILL DOES NOT.
PROVIDE -- A SOLUTION FOR GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS ONE GENDERED ATHLETIC
COMPETITIONS TO CONTINUE ON
STATE LANDS.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THE OTHER THING THAT THE
BILL DOESN'T DO YOU.
IS IT DOESN'T REQUIRE PARITY AND
THE LENGTH OF A COMPETITIVE
COMPETITIVE EVENTS IN MAY THE
AMGEN TOUR WHICH IS A A A
CYCLING RACE THAT GOES THE
ENTIRE LENGTH OF CALIFORNIA.
IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE THE WOMEN
CYCLE LISTS HAVE A WOMEN'S RACE
AND THURMOND CYCLISTS HAVE A
MEN'S RACE THEIR TWO
CORRESPONDING RACES.
THE WOMEN GET THREE DAYS TO
COMPETE THE MEN GET SEVEN DAYS
TO COMPETE.
THIS SORT OF IN EQUITY IS GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION AND THIS
BILL NEEDS TO BE AMENDED TO
CORRECT THAT SITUATION THE AMGEN
TOUR TAKES PLACE ON STATE ROAD
WAYS.
SO WE'RE SEEKING TO GET THOSE
THINGS CORRECTED OKAY THANK YOU.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO KIND OF
REMIND EVERYONE THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE THAT WAS POLICY.
WE SHOULD DISCUSS THAT COMPONENT
IN THE POLICIES SECTION.
WITHIN ENTERTAINMENT SO JUST
BRING IT BACK MY FAULT.
NO NO NO PROMISED QUIRK THAT WAS
OF THE GENERAL QUESTION BUT AYE
AYES.
WE WERE GETTING A LITTLE BIT
STRETCHED OUTSIDE.
SO BRAIN BACK OR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE BECAUSE WE DID
DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT OF POLICY I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO IF SHE WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS SPECIALLY FOLKS THAT
ARE WATCHING.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL ON
IT IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT ON AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY --
THIS DID PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF POLICY COMMITTEE THIS BILL
FOCUSES ONLY ON EQUAL
COMPENSATION PRIZES FOR MALE
FEMALE ATHLTES.
IT DOES NOT TALK ABOUT INCLUSION
AND IS SILENT ON THAT ISSUE AND
THE REASON IS THERE'S A GREAT
DISPARITY ON THE INCLUSION.
ISSUE AND SO WHAT I'VE TALKED
WITH WITH THE SELECT COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE
IS.
WILL PERHAPS HAVE A HEARING IN
THE FALL TO ACTUALLY DISCUSS THE
ISSUE OF INCLUSION WHICH IS MUCH
MORE COMPLEX THAN THE
COMPENSATION PRIZE -- COMPONENT
THIS BILL IT WAS BASED ON THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATE LANDS
DECISION THAT REQUIRED -- EQUAL
COMPENSATION PRICES FOR MEN AND
WOMEN AND SO WITH THIS IS A THAT
ONE FOCUS OF THIS BILL I HEAR
THE THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION -- BUT THIS BILL HAS
BEEN -- ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
FORMS OF THIS WAS INTRODUCED SO --
BECAUSE IT PASSED TO POLICY
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY -- AND IS
THE FISCAL COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOES ANYONE
ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THIS DOESN'T JOY TO PASS --
RECOMMENDATION IS GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU THANK [inaudible]
MISS LAMONT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
STRENGTHENS THE EXISTING LAW TO
REDUCE THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CONTINUOUS SO AND WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO I MOTION
IN SESSION.
SO I'M HAPPY TO MAKE A QUICK
REMARKS -- BUT JUST TO SAY THAT
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE IS A NECESSARY TOOL AND I
HOPE THAT -- I CAN ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
SHERRI PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE FILE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
YES SIR.
I DO NOT SEE YOU WALKING ON GOOD
MORNING.
WHEN YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE P. ANTHONY THOMAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA?
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN OPPOSITION
TO AS WE WERE IN POLICY
COMMITTEE -- TO EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE I MISS INTO THE
THERE ARE -- TWENTY FOUR OIL AND
GAS LEASES LEFT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- TWENTY FOUR NINE
ACCORDING TO THE COMEDIAN
ALICE'S ARE NOT PRODUCING.
THE QUESTION IS SINCE THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION HIS CAR IS
CURRENTLY IN POWER. TO OVERSEE
ANY TRANSFER OF PLEASE OF WHAT
REASON IS A STATE CONSERVING
PUTTING MORE THE TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS INTO A SYSTEM THAT
CURRENTLY HAS SPECIFIC
PARAMETERS.
I WOULD DEFER TO FORMER GOVERNOR
BROWN'S -- VETO MESSAGE OF MISS
LAMONT FOURTEEN OF SEVENTY TWO
LAST YEAR IN PART SAYING THE
COMMISSION HAS BROAD AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS WHETHER AN APPLICANT.
IS ABLE TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE PROPOSAL LEASE.
HE CONCLUDED THAT THE BILL WAS
UNNECESSARY AND WE SEE THE SAME
REASONING AND REFERENCE TO IT
THIS YEAR.
THERE'S NO NEED TO EXPAND
RESOURCES WHEN THE COMMISSION
CAN PERFORM THE DUTIES TO THE
FULLEST ABILITIES -- WE WOULD
ASTRONOMICAL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING MEMBERS.
DID I UNDERSTAND THAT LAST
STATEMENT CORRECT.
YOU ASKED FOR AND I BOTH KNOW I
ASK FOR A NO VOTE UNITS HE
MISUNDERSTOOD.
JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR HERE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE IT IT'S BEEN A IT'S
BEEN A LONG WEEK HAS VOTING OF
MARKETING.
WE WERE LAST WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I DIDN'T SEE HIM
COMING OUT SO I RECOGNIZE
DEMOCRACY.
MEMBERS ARE THESE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR.
SAYING NOT THIS ENJOYS A DO
PASSES GETS OUT -- ON OF THE
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU.
THIS CALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH SIX
UPDATES LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
CITATION PENALTY ITSELF.
AS TENNIS LEGEND CARE TO
SAFEGUARD NURSING HOME LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY RESIDENTS -- STUFF
WITH THE REPLACE CAUSATION
STANDARD A GERMAN CLASS EIGHT
VIOLATIONS THE DEATH OF A
RESIDENT OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY WITH MORE APPROPRIATE
AND LEGALLY ACCEPT A SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR DEFINITION.
ADDITIONALLY AB FIVE OR SIX
ACTUALLY IT'S RECENT STATE OUT
OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY CITATION
AMOUNTS WHICH IS NOT CHANGING
EIGHT YEARS CLASS BE CITATIONS.
AND HAVE NOT CHANGED NINETEEN
YEARS CLASS A. IN DOUBLY
CITATIONS.
AS IN AUS NOTES COST THE BILL OR
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE AS THE BILL
SIMPLY CLARIFYING EXISTING BY
THE VIOLATION DEFINITION OPPOSED
BY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
USING A STENCIL BACKED UP INTO
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT OF PROPERLY
IMPOSE CLASS.
DOUBLE A VIOLATION WINNER MORE
INTO THEIR BY SAFEGUARDING
NURSING HOME AND OTHER LONG TERM
CARE.
FACILITY RESIDENTS STRICTLY
ASPEN.
JIMMY FROM GOING TO DISBELIEVE
AS CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IS
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER SIGN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES WAS REPRESENTS ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOUR HUNDRED INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES.
OF WE ARE THE WE WE WOULD AGREE
THAT THIS BILL PROBABLY DOESN'T
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON DIRECT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WE DO THINK
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A DRAMATIC
IMPACT.
ON MEDI CAL FUNDING FOR OUR
FACILITIES WHICH IN MANY CASES
ARE A 100% MEDI CAL FUNDED -- BY
CHANGING THE CAUSATION STANDARD
BY WHICH THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
DETERMINE A DOUBLE A CITATION
WHICH THAT VIOLATION IS THE
HIGHEST VIOLATION THAT A
FACILITY CAN RECEIVE.
AND THEY WILL BE INCENTIVIZE
OBVIOUSLY TO AND HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH MORE OF THOSE VIOLATIONS
WHICH WE THINK WILL RESULT IN A
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL FACILITIES
HAVING TO PAY ADDITIONAL.
EXTREME HIGH FINES AND THAT WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT ON MEDICARE
FUNDING FOR PATIENT CARE SO WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION -- WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THE AUTHOR
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
ISSUES BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE TO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION OUR CONCERNS
ARE THE VERY SAME.
MANY OF OUR HOSPITALS THAT
OPERATE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE LOCATED IN RURAL
AREAS THESE ARE SMALL FACILITIES
AND WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THOSE
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE.
NO FILE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
MR QUIRK.
I'LL BE VOTING FOR THIS TODAY
BECAUSE THE STATE COSTS ARE --
MINOR BUT I DO HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
WE DON'T ASK [inaudible]
OKAY.
WITH THAT SAID SINCE THERE'S NO
OTHER QUESTIONS THIS BILL --
THIS BILL GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS -- ABSTAINING.
THE GREATEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS -- THOUGHT TO PRESENT
NOW AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ESPECIALLY TO
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL.
YEAH SO IT WAS A THIS IS A
PRIVATE COMPANY PARTNER CRACKS
RELOCATION ASSISTING ALLOWING
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS ARE BASS
EIGHTEEN OTHERWISE TAKEN BECAUSE
THE INDIVIDUALS TAKE CUSTODY.
PERMIT GRAYSON PURPOSES WHAT ARE
LAWS CLEAR ARE THE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION NATIONALITY ACT AND
ITS IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT BE ASKING
ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS BEN LONG CO
DIRECTOR FOR ASIAN VISITORS
SUPPORT COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OUR
NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS JUDY JANET LEGAL
SERVICES WERE PRISONERS IT WITH
CHILDREN WHERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESS AT
THE DICE THIS.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELA CHEN.
ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR TO SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT
ADVANCINGJUSTICE.
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS.
SO AB ONE TWO EIGHT TWO WOULD
PREVENT.
CDC ARE FROM EXPANDING ITS
RESOURCE THE PERSONAL TIME. TO
TURN OVER INDIVIDUALS OF OUR IN
THE RELEASE. TO PRIVATE SECURITY
CORPORATIONS THAT ISIS CONTRACT
WITH.
BOB FOR DEPORTATION PURPOSES.
AB ONE TWO WAY.
TO SAVE STATE RESOURCES.
BECAUSE THE AND THE PRACTICE OF
SUBJECTS EASIER TO POTENTIAL
LIABILITY.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
U. S. C. H. U. S. C..
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN CITIES
THERE SHOULD NOT BE TURNING OVER
INDIVIDUALS. TO PRIVATE SECURITY
CORPORATIONS FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
YOU FOR US WHICH IS THE MAIN.
SECURITY CORPORATION THAT'S USED
BY ICE TO PICK PEOPLE UP FROM
CDC ARE HAS A LONG TRACK RECORD
OF SUBJECTING INDIVIDUALS.
IN THEIR CUSTODY TO DANGEROUS
AND IN HUMANE CONDITIONS.
INCLUDING KEEPING KEEPING PEOPLE
LOCKED UP IN ADVANCE. FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME IN
EXTREME HEAT.
AND SUBJECTING THEIR DETAINEES
TO SEXUAL ASSAULT.
CITIES HERE COULD BE HELD LIABLE
FOR KNOWINGLY TURN -- RETURNING
OVER INDIVIDUALS TO TO DO FOR US
DESPITE THIS NOTORIOUS RECORD.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB.
ONE TWO EIGHT TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE THIS BILL GETS OUT
ON OF THE ROLL CALL MISTER DEEP
NOT VOTING THANK YOU.
WHICH WAS WITH MR MADE.
MR MAYS I BELIEVE YOU'RE.
HERE.
YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR MISTER --
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO I WANT TO PRESENT AB -- THREE
SEVEN SEVEN FOR US A MEMBER
GARCIA MOVE THE BILL.
SO THEN I'M GONNA GIVE THE SHORT
VERSION -- MAYBE THREE SEVEN
SEVEN IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO AB
SIX TWENTY SIX WHICH ESTABLISHED
MICRO ENTERPRISE HOME KITCHEN
OPERATIONS IS A NEW TYPE HAVE
RESTRICTED FOOD FACILITY
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WOULD RESPECT THE REQUEST
AND I HOPE.
VERY CONCISE DID WELL FOR MR
GARCIA.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BETSY I'M SORRY HAVE THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
JOHNSON CLAIMED TO HAVE THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE'RE SERVE A
TWEENER WE HAVE CONCERNS --
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND HOW
WOULD BE ROLLED OUT IN THE WHAT
IT WILL BASICALLY DO FOR THE
COUNTY SAN USE FORCE I STOPPED
EITHER TO MAKE A DECISION FOR
ALL EIGHTEEN CITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING SEEING NINE THIS BILL I
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU VERY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR.
YEAH OPALA GONNA GET MANAGE
[inaudible]
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO NOW.
QUICK RUN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURTESY ON
THE PREVIOUS.
THANK YOU MISTER MAC Là -- AB
SIX OH FIVE INSURERS THAT AS THE
BILL.
I THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
WHICH ISN'T SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER EDUCATIONAL
PARALEGAL AND SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF A POWER FAMILY --
CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF MY CLIENTS.
GOOD MORNING TERRY SANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
OKAY THAT BILL -- WHAT HAD A TO
PASS -- IF THERE IS -- BEGETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING --
MISTER DEEP VOTING I'D AND AND
MR BROKE VOTING I YOUR NEXT BILL
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR I WOULD
REQUIRE OSHA AT THOSE WORDS.
THANK THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANKS VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE SOMEBODY COMING IN
MOVING UP LIVING AROUND.
PLAYING MUSICAL CHAIRS --
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OR ON SUPPORT
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANDRE RIVER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS SEEN NOT.
ARE THIS BILL GETS OUT ON IF YOU
WILL CALL WHEN MR DEEP VOTING
AYE [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
AB.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
THIS BILL GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING THE
STURDY.
FORTY NINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AN EXCEL PRESENT AB TEN
THIRTY WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
FIRST TIME GYNECOLOGICAL
PATIENTS RECEIVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
AND HOPEFULLY PREVENT.
INSTANCES OF SEVERE MISCONDUCT
THIS ISSUE WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY.
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT WHO
WAS A VICTIM OF THE DOCTOR AT
USC RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY GOOD DEAL THANK YOU --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
QUESTIONS OF NUMBERS.
SEEING NONE ISN'T THIS A BILL
GETS OUT WITH ON A WILL CALL IN
MISTER OBERNOLTE NOT MANY.
THANKS MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NO -- MR SAKE OF THIS YOU'RE
SANTIAGO.
I SUSPECT THAT YOU'RE ONCE
BREVITY.
I A I WOULDN'T CHOI BREVITY I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE -- TWELVE FIFTY
ONE WELL SECOND.
I RESPECTFULLY -- BUT I THOUGHT
I HEARD A MOTION AND A SECOND I
EXPECT THAT FROM MY BOTH --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LOS ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE IS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE FIFTY ONE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE THIS ENJOYS THIS
GETS OUT ON A WILL CALL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESIDENT THE
SHEET THAT -- MISS CLARK WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO MR QUIRK YOU HAVE A BILL
EIGHTY TO NINETY TWO AND HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OF THE BILL.
IT'S THIS IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT --
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND BIGGEST AREAS OKAY AS AB
TWO NINE TO MODERNIZE IS TO
TERMS.
FOR A RECYCLED WATER IN.
MANY BILLS FRANKLY WE OUGHT TO
HAVE SOME SORT OF GENERAL POLICY
WHERE WE JUST WHEN WE NEED TO
MODERNIZE YOU CHANGE THE NAME TO
DEPARTMENTS.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE A BILL
TO DO THIS BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT
NOW.
THANK YOU.
WE AGREE ON THIS MISTER CLARK
Là WILL WORK ON IT NEXT YEAR.
WE WILL.
WHEN I WAS IN SUPPORT THAT'S ALL
ALSO ON BEHALF OF WATER REDUCE
CALIFORNIA THE SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
RAISE THE TIME SAID METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANTHONY TEN HELL CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
QUESTIONS FROM -- ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR.
MISTER QUIRK IT'S LIKE I SAID
IT'S A GOOD BILL I HOPE TO WORK
ON IT WITH YOU NEXT YEAR WE DO
NEED TO MODERNIZE.
I'M NOT THE BEST A CHANGING
SOMETIMES BUT I DO AGREE WITH
YOU IN THIS GREAT WILL DO IT
[inaudible]
WHERE?
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS HERE
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FORTY TWO A TWO MR BONTA.
MR DAILY.
MR GABRIEL MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SO IS THERE STAFF COULD -- MAYBE.
REACH OUT TO THEM WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
WOULDN'T.
PLEASE MR QUIRK.
MR WORK WILL BE PRESENTING FOR
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
I WILL GIVE YOU THAT MOMENT.
THAT IS.
EIGHTY NINE TWELVE IT HAS A TO
PASS AND IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
MOTEL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND IT'S
CARRILLO SECOND BY -- BY THE
CHAIR.
THIS BILL DELAYS FOR TEN YEARS
REQUIREMENT FOR AN OWNER
OPERATOR VESSEL TO MEET THE
FINAL.
CALIFORNIA PERFORMANCE STANDARD
FOR THE DISCHARGE OF BALLAST
WATER IS YEAR DETECTABLE LIVING
ORGANISMS IT'S BEING DELAYED
BECAUSE WE CAN'T MEET IT
TECHNICALLY [inaudible]
K. -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI SHERRY PEMBERTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT WE ARE WE
ARE -- UNFORTUNATELY PROPOSING
THAT WE DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE STANDARDS BECAUSE THERE
ISN'T TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE TO
MEET THEM.
DESPITE ALL OF OUR GREAT WORK
AND AND EFFORTS OTHERS A VARIETY
OF REASONS FOR THAT.
AND AND SOME HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI.
NINE TWELVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE IS BILL GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU.
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING FOR MR BONTA.
MR DAILY MR GABRIEL.
AND MISTER JONES SAWYER --
MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I DID
THE END
[inaudible]
RIGHT
-- AB.
MR BONTA YOU HAVE.
EIGHTY SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE MOVE
THE BILL.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER BARTON THANK YOU -- MINOR
AND ABSORB ACOSTA A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY NINE TO PROMOTE GREATER
SAFE PUBLIC SAFETY MORE
CONFERENCE OF POLICY ENFORCEMENT --
WITH ME HERE IS ACTUALLY AIRS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVE YOUR BEST AT THANK YOU
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR SO AGAIN MY NAME
IS ACTUALLY YOURS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY OF ETCETERA.
A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE I WOULD LIKE
TO THINK OF SOMETHING OVER
MONSTER FOR ALL THREE A BILL
THAT WOULD ATTEMPT TO KEEP THE
DEPARTMENTS DEALER RECORD OF
SALE FUND SOLVENT -- WE ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD
DâN RE WITH NATURAL SOCIAIS
SHOWN ALSO YOUR FIRST YEAR PA
TODAY.
IN OPPOSITION -- THIS BILL SEEKS
TO DOUBLE THE DEROSE V. FOR FARM
TRANSFERS -- THAT'S ONLY A
PORTION OF FEE THAT FARM OWNERS
PAY UPON THE TRANSFER OF FIREARM
IT'S CURRENTLY -- AND NINETEEN
DOLLARS THIS LOOKS TO DOUBLE
THAT THE WE SEEM TO DRAW SEE A
MASS.
SURPLUS IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IT'S BEEN BORROWED
FOR OTHER OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND AS MORE -- SO -- MORE
STRANGE BEEN PUT ON THIS PROGRAM
TO TAKE CARE OF OTHER DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE PROGRAMS IT'S GONE --
TO A PLACE WHERE IT'S SAFE GOING
TO BE INSOLVENT AND THIS IS
PUTTING THE FEEDBACK ON GUN
OWNERS AS WELL AS AUTHORIZING
THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS FOR MANY
MANY MORE ACTIVITIES -- I THINK
BEFORE WE START WRITING A BLANK
CHECK OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO RAISE THE FEE ON GUN
OWNERS.
WE SHOULD -- EXAMINE THAT AROSE
ACCOUNT AND SEE WHERE THOSE
MONIES ARE GOING -- WE KNOW THAT
AT ONE TIME -- TWENTY THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS BORROWED
FROM THAT ACCOUNT.
I MEAN THAT WAS AT A TIME WHEN I
WAS A MASSIVE HIT SURPLUS WERE
GUN SALES ARE HALF OF WHAT THEY
ARE TODAY FOR THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS WE'VE SEEN.
GOOD SALES -- SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS PER YEAR INCLUDING --
THERE'S ONE POINT THREE MILLION%
FARM SOLD IN A TWENTY SIXTEEN SO --
WORDS THAT MONEY GOING I THINK
WE NEED -- TO TAKE.
A REALLY CLOSE LOOK AT THAT
BEFORE WE AUTHORIZE -- MORE
MONEY THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
OUTDOOR SPORTS WAS COALITION
SPARKLE OF INTERNATIONAL
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY.
WE'RE ALL IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- MYSTERIES I THINK
COVERED IT REAL WELL -- I DID I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT THERE IS --
BUDGET AUGMENTATION THIS YEAR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND THAT'S
UNDERGOING BUDGET DISCUSSIONS WE
THINK THAT'S THE PROPER VENUE
THIS DOES CREATE A BLANK CHECK.
AND WE'RE ALL INTERESTED IN AND
THE ARM PROHIBITED PERSONS --
PROGRAM THAT HAS HAD A LOT OF
CHALLENGES OVER THE YEARS THEY
HAVE BORROWED FROM THE DROVES IN
THE PAST AND WE THINK THAT THE
OVERALL UNIT NEED TO DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE THE FUNDING STREAM AND
THAT WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE LAWSUITS PENDING ON
THE GIRLS COUNT.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN WAS CALIFORNIA
ECHOING THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES BUT THIS THIS.
FISCAL COMMITTEE SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED OVER THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS.
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PLUS
HAVE GONE INTO THE DRAWS FUND.
WHERE HAVE THOSE RESOURCES GONE
WE DO KNOW THAT EVERY TIME A
BILL COMES FORWARD -- HAVING TO
DO WITH -- SOME SORT OF GUN
ISSUE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE--
IT'S ALWAYS MINOR IN OBSERVABLE.
AS WAS POINTED OUT BY MY
COLLEAGUES THE DROSE FUND HAS
GONE FROM.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
SURPLUS TO DOWNLOAD TO TO MORE
AND MORE WITH NO IDENTIFICATION
AS TO WHERE THE MONEY IS BEING
SPENT.
THERE HAVE BEEN REQUESTS. FOR AN
AUDIT TO FIND OUT HOW WILL THOSE
RESOURCES ARE BEING SPENT.
WHICH AGENCIES OR THE GOVERNOR
OR THE LEGISLATURE HAVE BORROWED
FROM THAT FUN AND AND WHEN YOU
BORROW.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO PAY IT BACK.
AND IN THE LEE FULL INTENTION OF
THIS LAW WAS ALWAYS TO COVER
CERTAIN COST AND WHEN IT.
WENT INTO SURPLUS THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO LOWER THOSE FEES IN
ORDER TO COVER THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
COSTS SO IT'S IT'S NO LONGER A
FEE BUT IT IS A TAX TO COVER.
ALL MANNER OF THINGS UNRELATED
TO THE TO THE PURCHASE AND
REGISTRATION AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS -- FOR FOR FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BOY.
YOU WANNA RIDE OF A A JUST A
OPEN CHECK WHEN SAY GO DO WHAT
EVER YOU WANT WITH IT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE YOU'VE HAD A STRENUOUS
DAY TODAY.
QUESTIONS MISTER QUIRK YES BUT I
HEAR FROM THE SUPPORTERS -- AS
TO HOW THE MONEY IS SPENT IN
THIS FUN JUST VERY BRIEFLY
COUPLE SENTENCES.
OF COURSE SIR SO AT THE WAY THE
FUNNY THING IS AT THE DIRECTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE SO LAST YEAR
THERE WERE EIGHTEEN BILLS THAT
WERE PASSED IN IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF FIRES ALL THAT WERE.
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS AN
ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS ON THE
DEPARTMENT FROM THE EXAMPLES
INCLUDE.
I THE THE GHOST GONNA SEE
REALIZATION ASSAULT WEAPON
REGISTRATION AB THESE ARE ALL
THE TYPES OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE PLACED ON THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT TAP INTO THE DEALER RECORD
ITSELF SO THESE ARE ALL WITH THE
CLEAR NEXUS YES OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OF THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
THOUGHT.
THANK YOU -- VERY MUCH THIS BILL
GETS OUT WITH THE REPUBLICAN
WELL ONE OF THE ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
REALLY DID YOU FIND OUT THE
MAJOR.
OKAY MR GABRIEL I'M SORRY.
IS GABRIEL WE'RE TAKING.
AB THREE THREE ZERO THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY.
WE HAVE A MUCH MY MISS CARRILLO
SECOND BY MISTER REED.
I'LL BE QUICK THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THREE THREE ZERO WHICH ARE
EXPAND FUNDING FOR THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL SARGENT SHRIVER.
CIVIL COUNCIL ACT PILOT PROGRAMS
THESE PILOT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
VITAL LEGAL REPRESENTATION TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN LIFE
CHANGING CIVIL LEGAL MATTERS.
AB THREE THREE ZERO INCREASES
THE FILING FEES THAT FUND THE
SHRIVER ACT PROGRAMS TO HELP
SERVE MORE LITIGANTS ALLOW
PROGRAMS TO HELP SERVE.
OTHER UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
EXPAND SERVICES TO CRITICAL
AREAS SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
[inaudible]
NO.
FIVE YES NO FILE.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR SCENE --
NINE THIS BILL GETS OUT ON AT
THE ROLL CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I'M SORRY MR DEEP NOT FULLY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY. ONE OF WE LET'S DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WOULD.
YOU MIND READING THE MOVE.
QUESTION I MOVE MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IN A SECOND ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
COULD YOU PLEASE READ OUR AB
342-072-40260 729-330-5360
1-398-440-7403 484-874-88490
EIGHT FIVE OR 455-354-08560.
660-864-09680 670-917-7147
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN THIRTY SIX
AND 477-547-61780 586-864-98290 --
899-310-0010 371-040-41080 FOUR
THAT A TWENTY NINE AND THEN
791-213-1230 512-371-24012
941-319-1320. 713-721-38413
921-414-1470 314-931-51416
221-651-1720 1-794-180-0180 AND
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO READ THE
SUSPENSE FILE [inaudible]
NOT REALLY.
I KNOW YOU CAN TALK SLOWER.
WE'LL GIVE HIM TIME.
861-516-3030 740-160-6360
869-131-4041 521-731-77180
319-422-9230 424-052-4072 GIVE
YOU ONE TICKET IN.
1-974-283-2852 930-831-9320
633-834-01360 336-536-8380
339-341-1417 429-440-1440
847-949-1490 SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED
FIVE TWELVE BY. 295-375-71570
761-462-5620 864-066-40860
866-667-8680 1-685-691-6947
001-702-7047. 1-872-722-7317.
487-575-9790 880-380-7820
483-583-8840 ONE EIGHT FORTY
THREE EIGHT FORTY EIGHT EIGHT
FIFTY TWO A 658-798-3858
979-149-18930. 394-029-54950
596-962-9769 EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE NINETY FIVE JAN
311-033-1030 FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
TEN FIFTY ONE TO SIXTY ONE TO
SET.
752-771-0852 922-932-9711
004-110-51113. ELEVEN NINETEEN
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO OH TO TALK.
FOURTEEN FOR THIRTY THREE TWELVE
FORTY SIX TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO OF
881-300-1306. THIRTEEN OH NINE
THIRTEEN TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY EIGHT THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FOURTEEN OH THREE
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
FOURTEEN SIXTY TO FOURTEEN
NINETY SIX FIFTEEN OH ONE
FIFTEEN FORTY NINE FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR SIXTEEN OH ONE
316-141-63616.
451-658-1670 1-167-917-0817
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
EIGHT YOU KNOW.
ONE AND A CA.
ONE SOLD TO THE GOOD GENTLEMAN
THAT WAS STANDING AT THE PODIUM
HE TAKES ALL OF THOSE ITEMS AT
ONE PRICE TODAY.
THOUGH IT THAT WAS OUR SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. FOR THE DAY.
STIR JONES SAWYER YOU HAVE TO
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY.
GRAVITY ISN'T CURRY'S STAND
LET'S START WITH.
AB TEN NINETY ONE MOVE THE BILL
SECOND.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND YOU HAVE A
SECOND -- HAVING TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SIR.
DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO YES I DO ON
OCT -- HERE BUT LET'S JUST GO
FOR IT OKAY OKAY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TEN NINETY ONE WOULD EXTENDED
IMPROVE EXISTING LAW THAT ALLOWS.
PARENTS TO ASSIST.
SUSPEND THEIR CHILDREN THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS WHILE
THEY ARE INCARCERATED.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS FOR THE
SUSPENSION OF PAYMENT UPON
INCARCERATION HOWEVER THIS LAW
IS SET TO SUNSET ON JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY AB TEN NINETY MY
WILL REMOVE TO SENSE THAT THEY
TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM PERMANENT
THIS BILL ALSO MAKES TO
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING LOT
ACKNOWLEDGE.
THE CHALLENGES FORMING CARCERI
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL FACING RE
ENTERING SOCIETY SUCH AS GIVING
PARENTS THREE MONTHS BEFORE THE
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS RESUME.
MEMBERS THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND
ABSORB.
I'M SO SAY WITH ME TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF HIS MEASURES JUST
PARK BOTTOM YOU FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW POVERTY AND I
DON'T SEE HIM BUT HE WAS ECHO
THE EXACT SAME THING I JUST SAID.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HEARD
MINOR THAT'S HORRIBLE.
WHAT DO YOU?
KNOW FILE NO.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
IS A BILL GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL MR
SO YEAH.
THANK YOU AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE IT
DOES HAVE TO DO PASSED SUPPORT
SUPPORT.
WELL THE BILL WE HAVE SECOND AND
ONE WE HAVE A SECOND.
ON THE PREVIOUS ITEM I DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE MISTER ROLE IS NOT
VOTING THAT WAS ON TEN NINETY
ONE JUST FOR CLARIFICATION FOR
THE RECORD -- MISTER SAWYER
PLEASE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU -- I'M HERE TO PRESENT
A BEAST TWELVE SIXTY ONE A BILL
THAT AT LEAST A REQUIREMENT FOR
NOT **** OFFENDERS TO REGISTER
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON
CONVICTED OF CERTAIN DRUG
OFFENSES IS REQUIRED TO RESEARCH
REGISTER WITH THEIR LOCAL POLICE.
CHIEF OR SHERIFF THIS IS AN
INEFFICIENT COSTLY EVERY TENDER
PROCESS GIVEN THAT ALL OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IN THE
REGISTRY CAN BE FOUND IN A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL RECORD.
AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE WOULD DELETE
THE REQUIREMENT OF NARCOTICS
OFFENDERS TO REGISTER WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COURTS VALUABLE
TIME AND RESOURCES.
AS IN ALICE'S POINTS OUT THIS
BILL.
HAS MINOR AND ABSORB MOBILE COST
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
UPDATE TO CO TABLES USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE BUT I IF
YOU WERE HERE. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WOULD HAVE
BEEN LARRY DORAL REPRESENTED
CONFERENCE ON CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
NO FILE THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
IT'S JUST SO YOU'RE THE BILL
GETS OUT WITHIN A ROLL CALL YOU
GRADUATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BIGELOW.
THANK YOU FOR RESPONDING TO CALL
US BY THE WAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
THE DAY WE DO HAVE.
ONE ITEM -- BEFORE IT'S ON AT
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WERE WITHDRAW THE
MOTION ON THAT -- ITEM.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION SEEN NO
OBJECTION.
THAT IS WITHDRAWN.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
THE DAY.
WE STAND ADJOURNED